Wow I'm in the stuff credit guy remember
it so you don't have to are you sick of
frozen yet well there's a lot of people
mostly kids who clearly aren't around
every corner you see another product of
merchandise another screen showing it
another playing of the soundtrack it's
all over the place if you play let it go
in a room full of kids
chances are every single one of them
would start singing along not
surprisingly this has driven many of us
insane in fact I even did a musical
version talking about how it's all over
the place that's almost a year old now
and it still hasn't gone away this is
result in what usually follows something
that's insanely popular the backlash
suddenly a lot of people are coming out
saying the film is over praise to hyped
up and not even very good the film is
gone from one of the most beloved hits
of the past decade to one of the most
annoying by several viewers well clearly
so overexposed we want to bash our
brains in with the decapitated I sculpt
your whole off is the film itself really
deserving of such hate it still seems
like a good movie
not perfect but few if any films are so
why all the hatred towards the film as
opposed to the overexposure of it I mean
everybody left and right used to praise
this and now it seems to be working
towards the other direction and this is
unlike Shakespeare or comic book movies
where they're so popular we get to see
different takes and interpretations
we're talking about watching the exact
same thing line for line over and over
with no change whatsoever on the one
hand you can always pick up elements
about a movie you've never noticed the
more times you watch it hell I do a
whole series about that now but when
something is everywhere you turn and I
mean everywhere you start to tell
yourself enough is enough
I love guardians of the galaxy but if I
was forced to see a front and center in
every store every single place I turned
chances are most of us will have the
same tired reaction that doesn't mean it
would be any less a good film we would
just be sick of it being shoved in our
faces all the time
is it possible that overexposure as well
as hype can destroy what was originally
a good product this isn't the first time
we've seen something like this before
Big Fat Greek Wedding was a surprise hit
with audiences and critics alike but
want to start getting talked about a
little too much a backlash started to
form there as well same thing happened
to a Christmas Story
he used to be beloved by almost everyone
who saw it but now with countless
merchandise and even a 24-hour marathon
many of just plain grown sick of it
part of that may have to do that the
original charm of the product came from
the fact that very few knew about it
Christmas story used to be something of
an underground secret that kind of
naughty Christmas movie where kids would
swear and punch each other but still
return to a loving small-town nature
that felt warm and genuine with the
oversaturation of it though
that secret little film is now a
multi-million dollar enterprise and when
something becomes more and more
commercialized it feels less and less
personal the toys of land's went from
sort of the secret handshake among
selected viewers to repulsive Kitsch
that most people are just sick to death
of yet the film itself hasn't shaped
it's exactly the same get our feelings
towards it start to alter a little bit
when we start to see it everywhere
sometimes people can feel a stronger
connection to something if you were know
about it element it was a little weird
seeing the Lord of the Rings on the big
screen yeah they were great movies and
changed a lot of cinema forever but
before that it was something that made
you feel a bit more unique for knowing
about it
the books were popular obviously but not
a household name like they are today you
felt a bit more of a connection when you
found someone who did read the books and
could talk about it in as much detail as
you could when the movies came out
everybody knew about Lord of the Rings
and with the popularity of something
great you want to share also comes the
loss of feeling like you discovered
something unique it used to be you like
lore the Rings so do I maybe you and I
have a pretty cool connection now it's
you like Laura the Rings no shit
fucking everybody does how are you any
different from anybody else it's a
double-edged sword with many pros and
cons yeah that's great the more
attention is being given to something
that you consider good but does that
also take away a closer feeling you had
about it
interestingly enough though while the
film itself doesn't change your reaction
to watching a Ken and this is once again
where audience participation plays a big
part two films I thought were comic
masterpieces when they first came to the
big screen we're Borat and there's
something about Mary the audiences at
both the viewings I was at were howling
with laughter and
was their howling along with them when I
was done watching each film I remember
saying to myself these are some of the
best comedies ever by God I never saw an
audience laugh so much but then when I
watched them alone at home it was a very
different experience suddenly the shock
value didn't seem so shocking and the
humor seemed a little slower and more
awkward than I remembered they were
still okay but what happened between
watching it with an audience and
watching it on my own how did I go from
roaring with laughter - just a little
giggle every once in a while the films
themselves were exactly the same so how
come they weren't making me laugh as
hard it was then I realized just how big
an impact your environment can have bora
plays great - a crowd because it's jokes
are shocking enough to get a big laugh
but also slow enough so that you don't
miss a the jokes that follow but on its
own the shock value isn't as offensive
because you're not surrounded with as
many people laughing along with it
sharing an experience with a crowd where
you know is something is wrong but
you're gonna laugh along with it anyway
you feel kind of naughty for doing so
but you're doing it with a group and
therefore it feels much bigger and much
grander but when you're watching it on
your own not only is the experience gone
but the pacing seems kind of weird
because they left in a lot of long
pauses where the laughter is supposed to
go so now the movie seems kind of slower
and not as quick because there's not as
many distractions with the crowd this is
why some of these sitcoms still have
live audiences if you hear a large
amount of people laughing it'll in force
even if subtly that you should laugh -
logically if so many people are having a
good time that must mean there's
something funny about it
right how was funny with these sitcoms
be if they took out all that laughter
some can still hold up but a lot of them
really rely on it as we discover certain
movies do - but as we noticed before
height can work against a movie as well
if there's anything we're starting to
learn here it's that repetition is fine
but the more and more you do it the more
and more boring it starts to become
especially when you have other versions
to compare it to John Cleese still
stands by the fierce creatures is not a
bad film but because they used the same
cast as the oscar-winning Fish Called
Wanda it was hated and despised by
audiences and critics alike
- overexposure can be helpful but sadly
it can kind of be unfair it can affect
us in ways that we're consciously not
even aware of it can change our reaction
to a second viewing even if the movie
hasn't changed at all but something that
should also be picked up very quickly is
that people always want to make a big
deal out of something
remember when Twilight was everywhere
remember when transformers was
everywhere remember when Jim Carrey's
Grinch was everywhere yeah
remember kids Christmas isn't bought at
a store now please buy our board game
toys and a whole bunch of other shitty
merchandise yeah you can't escape it for
a while but that's my point there's
always going to be something people are
going to obsess over for a long period
of time so I suppose all we can really
do is hope that the obsession is over
something good rather than over
something bad with that said I much
rather take this shit over vishen any
day I much rather watch Elsa build a
castle than Bella and Edward kiss I much
rather see Ralphie and his mother bond
than see Jim Carrey forcing a guy to
kiss a dog's ass I much rather see Luke
Skywalker destroy the Death Star than
Michael Bay jerking off to his boy toys
and sure we'll start to get tired of
seeing them everywhere but we should be
happy we appreciated something that had
so much creativity to begin with years
ago people were sick of seeing Lion King
everywhere now it's a movie most people
when dream of being without remember how
everyone wouldn't shut up about the Dark
Knight but now you put on every once in
a while and still good flick we're gonna
go through a love and hate relationship
of anything that gets popular but it's
good to know that for every terrible
piece of crap that becomes a phenomenon
there's something intelligent and
inspiring that's waiting to become just
as popular if you're gonna be sick of
something you're gonna see over and over
just pray it's something you at least
kind of light to begin
I'm gonna stash a good guy remember it
so you don't have
hey guys Doug Walker here you want to
see me in person are you in the Alabama
area we'll go ahead and come on down to
comic-con that is from February 27th to
March 1st I'm there as a guess I'm going
to be signing autographs
so I'm merchandise and of course doing
panels and I'm really looking forward to
coming back so hopefully I'll see you
guys there
take care